this is Lisa doll
Lisa doll is one of the world's greatest
go players and he's having what my
friends in Silicon Valley call holy cow
moment a moment where we realize that AI
is actually progressing a lot faster
than we expected so humans have lost on
the go board what about the real world
well the real world is much bigger much
more complicated than the go board it's
a lot less visible but it's still a
decision problem and if we think about
some of the technologies that are coming
down the pike
so Noriko mentioned that reading is not
yet happening in machines at least with
understanding but that will happen when
that happens very soon afterwards
machines will have read everything that
the human race has ever written and that
will enable machines along with the
ability to look further ahead than
humans can as we've already seen and go
if they also have access to more
information they'll be able to make
better decisions in the real world than
we can so is that a good thing well I
hope so our entire civilization
everything that we value is based on our
intelligence and if we had access to a
lot more intelligence then there's
really no limit to what the human race
can do and I think this could be as some
people have described it the biggest
event in human history so why are people
saying things like this that AI might
spell the end of the human race is this
a new thing is it just a landmark and
Bill Gates and Stephen Hawking actually
know this idea has been around for a
while here's a quotation even if we
could keep the machines in a subservient
position for instance by turning off the
power
strategic moments and I'll come back to
that turning off a power idea later on
we should as a species feel greatly
humbled so who said this this is Alan
Turing in 1951 Alan Turing as you know
is the father of computer science and in
many ways the father of AI as well so if
we think about this problem the problem
of creating something more intelligent
than your own species we might call this
the gorilla problem because gorillas
ancestors did this a few million years
ago and now we could ask the gorillas
was this a good idea so here they are
having a meeting to discuss whether it
was a good idea and after a little while
they conclude no it was a terrible idea
our species is in dire straits in fact
you can see the existential sadness in
their eyes so this queasy feeling that
making something smarter than your own
species is maybe not a good idea what
can we do about that well really nothing
except stop doing AI and because of all
the benefits that I mentioned and
because I'm an AI researcher I'm not
having that I actually want to be able
to keep doing AI so we actually need to
nail down the problem a bit more what
exactly is the problem why is better AI
possibly a catastrophe so here's another
quotation we had better be quite sure
that the purpose put into the machine is
the purpose which we really desire this
was said by Norbert Wiener in 1960
actually shortly after he watched one of
the very early learning systems learn to
play checkers better than its creator
but this could equally have been said by
King Midas the King Midas that I want
everything I touched the turn to Gold
and he got exactly what he asked for
that was the purpose that he put into
the machine so to speak and then his
food and his drink and his relatives
turned to gold and he died in misery and
starvation so we'll call this the King
Midas problem of stating and objective
which is not in fact
truly aligned with what we want in
modern terms we call this the value
alignment problem so putting in the
wrong objective actually is not the only
part of the problem there's another part
if you put an objective into a machine
even something as simple as fetch the
coffee the machine says to itself
well how might I fail to fetch the
coffee someone might switch me off okay
I have to take steps to prevent that I
will disable my off switch I will do
anything to defend myself against
interference with this objective that
I've been given so this single-minded
pursuit in a very defensive mode of an
objective that is in fact not aligned
with the true objectives of the human
rate that's the problem that we face and
in fact that's the high value takeaway
from this talk if you want to remember
one thing it's that you can't fetch the
coffee if you're dead okay very simple
just remember that repeat it to yourself
three times a day and in fact this is
exactly the plot of 2001 how has an
objective immission which is not aligned
with the objectives of the humans and
that leads to this conflict
unfortunately how is not super
intelligent he's pretty smart but
eventually Dave outwit him and manages
to switch him off but we might not be so
lucky
so what are we going to do I'm trying to
redefine AI to get away from this
classical notion of machines that
intelligently pursue objectives there
are three principles involved the first
one is the principle of altruism if you
like that the robots only objective is
to maximize the realization of human
objectives of human values and by values
here I don't mean touchy-feely
goody-goody values
I just mean whatever it is that the
human would prefer their life to be like
and so this actually violates Asimov's
laws that the robot has to protect its
own existence it has no interest in
preserving its existence whatsoever
the second law is the law of humility if
you like and this turns out to be really
important to make robots safe it says
that the robot does not know what those
human values are so it has to maximize
them but it doesn't know what they are
and that avoids this problem of
single-minded pursuit of an objective
its uncertainty turns out to be crucial
now in order to be useful to us it has
to have some idea of what we want it
attains that information primarily by
observation of human choices so our own
choices reveal information about what it
is that we prefer our life to be like so
those are three principles let's see how
that applies to this question of of can
you switch the Machine off as Turing and
suggested so here's a pr2 robot this is
one that we have in our lab and it has a
big red off switch right on the back and
the question is is it going to let you
switch it off so if we do it the
classical way we give it the objectives
of fetch the coffee I must fetch the
coffee
I can't fetch the coffee if I'm dead so
obviously the pr2 s and listening to my
talk and so it says ok therefore I must
disable my off switch and probably taser
all the other people in Starbucks who
might interfere with me
so this is this seems to be inevitable
like this kind of failure mode seems to
be inevitable and it follows from having
a concrete definite objective so what
happens if the machine is uncertain
about the objective well it reasons in a
different way says okay the human might
switch me off but only if I'm doing
something wrong well I don't really know
what wrong is but I know that I don't
want to do it so that's the first and
second principle right there so I should
let the human switch me off and in fact
you can calculate the incentive that the
robot has to allow the human to switch
it off and it's directly tied to the
degree of uncertainty about the
underlying objective and then when the
machine is switched off that third
principle comes into play it learns
something about the objectives that it
should be pursuing that it learns what
it do wasn't right in fact we can you
know with suitable use of Greek symbols
as mathematicians usually do we can
actually prove a theorem it says that
such a robot is provably beneficial to
the human you are provably better off
with a machine that's designed in its
way than without it this is a very
simple example but this is the first
step in in what we're trying to do with
human compatible AI now this third
principle I think is the one that you're
probably scratching your head you're
probably thinking well you know I
behaved badly I don't want my robot to
behave like me all right you know I
sneaked out in the middle of the night
and I take stuff from the fridge I do
this I do that there's all kinds of
things you don't want the robot to be
doing but in fact it doesn't quite work
that way just because you behave badly
it doesn't mean the robots in a copy
your behavior it's going to understand
your motivations and maybe help you
resist them if appropriate but it's
still difficult right what we're trying
to do in fact is to allow machines to
predict for any person and for any
possible life that they could live and
the lives of everybody else which would
they prefer
and there are many many difficulties
involved in doing this and I don't
expect that this is going to get solved
very quickly and the real difficulties
in fact are us as I have already
mentioned we behave badly and some in
fact some of us are downright nasty now
the robot as I said doesn't have to copy
the behavior the robot does not have any
objective of its own it's purely
altruistic and it's not designed just to
satisfy the desires of one person the
user but in fact it has to respect the
Preferences of everybody so it can deal
with a certain amount of nastiness and
it can even understand that your
nastiness for example you know you may
take bribes as a passport official
because you need to feed your family and
send your kids to school and you can
understand that it doesn't mean it's
gonna steal in fact it'll just help you
send your kids to school we are all so
computationally limited so Lisa Dahl is
a brilliant go player but he's still
lost so if we look at his actions he
took an action that lost the game that
doesn't mean that he wanted to lose so
in order to understand his behavior we
actually have to invert through a model
of human cognition that includes our
computational limitations and that's a
very complicated model but it's still
something that we can work on
understanding probably the most
difficult part from my point of view as
an AI researcher is the fact that there
are lots of us and so the machine has to
somehow trade-off weigh up the
preferences of many different people and
there are different ways to do that
economists sociologists moral
philosophers have understood that and we
are actively looking for collaboration
so let's have a look and see what
happens when you get that wrong so you
can have a conversation for example with
your intelligent personal assistant that
might be available in a few years time
think is a theory on steroids so Siri
says your wife's call to remind you
about dinner tonight and of course
you've forgotten what what dinner what
are you talking about your 20th
anniversary at 7:00
p.m. I can't do that I'm meeting with a
secretary-general at 7:30 happy does
that happen well I did warn you but you
overrode my recommendation well what am
I going to do I can't just tell him I'm
too busy don't worry I arranged for his
plane to be delayed some kind of
computer malfunction really you can do
that
he sends his profound apologies and
looks forward to meeting you for lunch
tomorrow so the values here there's
there's a slight mistake going on right
this is clearly following my wife values
which is happy wife happy life it could
go the other way so you could come home
after a hard day's work and if that's
okay I have long day no yes I didn't
even have time for lunch you must be
very hungry starving yeah could you make
some dinner that's something I need to
tell you there are humans in South Sudan
who are in more urgently than you so I'm
leaving make your own dinner so we have
to solve these problems and I'm looking
forward to working on them there are
reasons for optimism one reason is that
there is a massive amount of data
because remember I said they're going to
read everything that human rate has ever
written most of what we write about is
human beings doing things and then other
people getting upset about it so there's
a massive amount of data to learn from
there's also a very strong economic
incentive to get this right so imagine
your domestic robots at home you're late
from work again the robot has to feed
the kids and the kids are hungry and
there's nothing in the fridge and the
robot sees the cat
and the robot hasn't quite learned the
human value function properly so it
doesn't understand the sentimental value
of the cat outweighs the nutritional
value of the cat and then so then what
happens well you know it it happens like
this deranged robot cooked Kitty's a
family dinner
that one that one incident would be the
end of the domestic robot industry so
there's a huge incentive to get this
right long before we reach super
intelligent machine
so to summarize I'm actually trying to
change the definition of AI so that we
have provably beneficial machines and
the principles are machines that are
altruistic that want to achieve only our
objectives but that are uncertain about
what those objectives are and we'll
watch all of us to learn more about what
it is that we really want and hopefully
in the process we will learn to be
better people thank you very much so so
interesting Joe we're going to
substantiate because I think they're
stepping up for our next speaker so cut
them in a couple of questions so in the
idea of programming in ignorance seems
intuitively but like really powerful as
you get to super intelligence what's
going to stop a robot reading literature
and discovering this idea that knowledge
is actually better than ignorance and
still just shifting its own goals and
kind of rewriting that that programming
yes that we want it to we want it to to
learn more as I said about our
objectives
it'll only you know it'll only become
more certain as it becomes more correct
right so the the evidence is there and
it's going to be designed to interpret
it correctly it will understand for
example that books a very biased in the
in the evidence they contain they only
talk about kings and princes and you
know elite white male people doing stuff
so it's a complicated problem but as it
learns more about our objectives it will
become more and more useful to us and
you couldn't just boil it down to one
law you know hardwired in if any human
ever tries to switch
be off I comply I comply absolutely not
that would be a terrible idea so imagine
that you know we have a self-driving car
and you want to send you a five-year-old
off to preschool I do you want your
five-year-old to be able to switch off
the car while it's driving along
probably not so it needs to understand
how rational and sensible the person is
the more rational the person the more
willing you are to be switched off if
the person is completely random or even
malicious then less you're less willing
to be switched off all right Stuart can
I just say I really really hope you
figure this out for us thank you so much
for that Joel it was amazing thank you